Hey Thoughty2 here.
The dark; for a long time we’ve suspected
it’s up to no good, only existing to provide
a hiding place for goblins, vampires and random
pieces of lego.
But it turns out that pretty much the entire
universe is made up of stuff that we cannot
see, cannot interact with and have no idea
what it is.
In fact, things we can see only make up a
pathetic 5% of existence.
So if you think your room looks messy now,
think what it would be like if you caught
a glimpse of the other 95%.
Yet we stumble through life like drunk, deaf
moles, barely taking in a fraction of everything
around us and somehow still manage to come
up with space travel, cancer treatments and
frozen yoghurt.
So what is the huge amount of other stuff?
Where did it come from?
Can I poke it and will it care if I do?
Does the dark matter?
The problem with the universe is that it’s
getting too fat and we need to find a way
to account for this.
Once we had realized that the universe was
expanding, we came up with two possible outcomes.
First, that the density of matter and energy
would eventually halt the continuous expansion
initiated by the big bang and then the universe
would collapse, disappearing back into a “big
crunch” singularity, or returning down the
back of God’s sofa, depending on what you
believe.
The second option was that it would keep expanding
forever but the expansion would slow down
by smaller and smaller increments.
The trouble was, when we pointed the Hubble
telescope at distant supernovae, not only
did we accidently catch them in the shower,
but we realized that in the past the universe
expanded slower than it did now.
That means not only is gravity not slowing
our expansion, something must be speeding
it up; we named this “something” dark
energy.
Dark Energy makes up 70% of the universe and
dark matter makes up 25% but these two things,
despite their name, didn’t appear as part
of the same concept – we needed each one
to account for different phenomena.
For dark energy, it was the swelling belly
of the universe, but dark matter was needed
to explain the unusually large mass of galaxies.
Jacobus Kapteyn and Jan Oort, after forming
the ministry of unusual names became astronomers
and theorized the idea of dark matter but
it was Swiss Astrophysicist Fritz Zwicky who
after also leaving the ministry of unusual
names, made the first formal theory about
its existence in 1933.
Zwicky was looking at a distant cluster of
galaxies and worked out that the motion of
the galaxies at the edge of the cluster was
much faster than it mathematically should
be.
Where was all this extra gravitational pull
coming from – there must a huge mass we
aren’t able to observe.
So the idea of dark matter was born; matter
which has mass, therefore gravity, but almost
no other interaction with baryonic matter,
which is what physicists call normal matter,
because they just have to have to come up
with a funky word for everything.
Alright then, so there is this huge amount
of stuff hiding in the cupboard.
Or, more accurately, we’re stuck in a tiny
cupboard and we have no idea what’s in the
rest of the house.
So do we know anything at all about dark matter?
Well yeah, we do.
We know that it’s primordial, meaning it
came from the big bang, since there’s no
realistic way for it to be continuously created.
Alright, that’s a start.
But then if it was all from the big bang and
it still exists now, then it must also be
stable, otherwise it would have changed into
something else.
So we assume dark matter conserves something
called parity, meaning that it can’t decay
into ordinary matter.
The simplest theory is that all dark matter
is of just one type called a WIMP; weakly
interacting massive particle.
So, they’re heavy but they are extremely
anti-social, rarely interacting with their
own kind, let alone with baryonic matter.
But try as we might, we’ve yet to see a
particle of dark matter.
But who wants a world full of WIMPs?
Bogdan Dobrescu and Don Lincoln have discussed
the idea of complex dark matter, these are
dark particles that interact with themselves
in the same way that ordinary matter does.
So it sounds like dark matter could just be
a mirror of baryonic matter, with all the
same rules and regulations.
But we know that this can’t be exactly true,
the similarities must end at some point because
we see that the mass given by dark matter
around galaxies is spread out in a sphere,
rather than a flattened disk that our galaxies
have.
But like ours, it could have hot and cold
particles.
Baryonic are cold matter but we also have
hot matter, better known as neutrinos – these
move close to light speed and have almost
zero mass.
Dark matter could have a similar spread with
hot and dark particles; which sounds like
an erotic sci-fi film, the cold dark particles
would be the WIMPs we discussed earlier.
The question is; are we ever going to find
any evidence for this or, just like Ben Affleck’s
acting ability, is it going to remain entirely
theoretical?
There are a number of different experiments
currently going on.
Some are just hoping to observe that incredibly
rare interaction between baryonic and dark
matter, by creating an extremely insulated
space where very little of the regular rays,
waves and particles pass through, creating
all their noise, and making it difficult to
see if any dark interactions are happening.
One such example is the Large Underground
Xenon Experiment that I have talked about
before, you can find a link to that video
in the description.
Another way may be to use our old friend the
Large Hadron Collider.
We won’t be able to observe it directly
in the detector but, in these powerful collisions,
it’s possible we could find some energy
that’s missing, perhaps showing that dark
emissions have occurred, accounting for this
lost energy.
Of course, if you really want baryonic matter
and dark matter to interact, you need to mix
dark rum and light rum and put on some Bob
Marley, it works at house parties at least.
And when it comes to finding dark energy,
well that’s equally problematic and we can
probably only observe its effects on a much
grander, galactic scale.
The Hobby-Eberly Telescope in Texas is hoping
to build a 3D map of the early universe and
so see more clearly what dark energy’s role
was in the development of the universe.
Who knows how much influence this spooky energy
and matter will prove to have on the world
we see around us.
Perhaps ghosts are just dark matter teenagers,
angrily slamming doors in an opposite world
right next to ours.
And hopefully the rapid expansion of dark
energy is the reason I had to buy a new belt
last week, it’s certainly not all the sausage
rolls.
Thanks for the view, subscribe for more Thoughty2.